once it feel like they'll shut the
selling record
the world time the new thing well it's
kind of a
Kennywood it's not true
joanne sky 90s icon the tours is great
sometimes even bringing things up the
kind of holt
lands breaking up with my band actually
i think you should just do something
else
i decided to enroll in a university out
here this kind of educate myself and and
go back to school seems sort of like a
grown-up decision why maybe that's why
I'm meant to be here because I meant to
educate them yeah because when women of
experience life experience sexual
experience teaching the fun of life what
do you do during freshman week of your
rave or some things are rape tonight
really not my right face let's go back
whoever has sex first gets fifty quid
I've seen your moves and I've seen your
dancing and I think I think there's
based in there got it yeah I'll be the
girl who who gets up on tables and
dances and falls in the face that guy
hey I can be that guy he's a nice guy
you think there's enough of you is that
what you're saying there are some good
things that came out of the nineties
yeah yeah like you
I don't know I've always felt like I've
just been racing racing Racing racing to
get to what I don't know is magic like
magic you're coming on with me yeah
[Music]
just keeping the focus you always want
to keep your focus you never take your
eyes off the target
hey Joe I really held back to you if I
would have gotten full force you would
not have been able to have children you
don't want full force
[Music]
you
you